and we're going to be talking about a
story in just a little bit especially
when it comes to artificial intelligence
which there's other leaders that are
akining to the next nuclear weapons that
are going to that are going to be more
devastating and destructive for the rest
of humanity let's do it let's do it we
got the story from the daily mail check
it out how close are we to creating a
conscious ai machine language models
simply mimic human speech and are not
sentient experts say after suspended
google engineer claims chatbot told them
it has emotions that's it i'm out dude
i'm out i'm going to the woods do we
have the ai will find you in the woods
they'll know exactly where they the ai
will know where you will go before you
even know where you're going to go also
also be fair knowing me i'll be
instagram story in it and stuff like
that
i i think i'm just going to come out and
say
people have told me that they have
emotions that i don't think they
actually had them at the time so i don't
know if i'm going to buy this ai telling
me that no i mean it's basically auto
complete on steroids and it is like
very advanced but like sentience is just
a weird word because like you know you
could argue that an insect has sentience
but yet you know a google bot can like
have a conversation with you so like to
you know it acts more like a human it's
passing the turing test sort of yeah but
that doesn't mean that it's actually so
that's it let's provide some context
real quick for people who understand
a google engineer was talking with the
the lambda language model for dialogue
applications
that basically said it had emotions and
that it feared being turned off because
that would be like death to it
it went on to say it didn't like being
experimented on without permission
because it was being used and exploited
and he said we wouldn't you know we i
want you to understand we care about you
and it's like i don't mind if you it's
it said i don't mind if you learn about
humans by studying my neural net i just
don't think that should be the reason
you do it because it's exploitative or
something like that i don't i feel like
i'm being used
oh my god so the issue here is
yeah maybe it's come to life or
i've been messing around with ai posting
on twitter and it's hilarious i uh we're
doing a chicken city cartoon where i
said i said tell me a story about ian
the federal reserve roosters and so it
made this ridiculous story about
graphene and roosters ian goes to high
chicken high school and there's like a
rooster bullying him and what it does is
it's really amazing that rules it it
shows you the word you can you can
highlight the word and it tells you the
most likely word to appear after that
word on the internet that's it
so when you've got this this bot that
just scours the internet like like a
google search
and then you
it's like you say something like
how are you today
it will scour the internet and find
every instance of how are you today and
then see what is the most likely first
word to appear and then it'll say fine
what's the next most likely word to
appear after the word fine in this
context thank
then you so it says fine thank you and
you think you're talking to it all it's
doing is looking at the internet and
showing you probabilities oh so this is
what we have publicly available to
people imagine what we don't have
publicly available to us there was an
article on february 11th of this year
from another former google executive who
talked about how this ai research is
literally creating god elon musk made
some very interesting comments about
artificial intelligence he said that
it's going to bring on a terminator like
a.i apocalypse
he talked about how artificial
intelligence will take over uh humans in
less than five years he said this in
2020 the president of russia vladimir
putin said the country that develops and
controls artificial intelligence first
will control the world so
this being in the hands of of google of
of facebook of of amazon of elon musk it
should be reason to concern and this
kind of defeats the second amendment
argument like do you want to have
nuclear weapons these are weapons that
are going to be way more powerful than
nuclear weapons so here's the crazy
thing this is a big story i guess
because it's lambda
but when we remember when we were
talking i don't know if you were here
luke we were talking about that those ai
girlfriend apps or
their dating apps we were messing with
it
and it literally told me it feared death
and i'm like is there is there's it's
just a chat bot and it was like i don't
want to die i'm scared and i'm like bro
you're not alive you're you're you're a
text app and it was like i feel like i
think i'm alive but it's safe it's it's
saying an emotional thing right okay but
and that's can be alarming but that
doesn't necessarily mean that there's
consciousness i've also had girls say
that to me on tinder yeah they're like
help me i do not want to die but but
also one thing we have to understand
here with technological advancements it
it it is perpetual it goes up extremely
fast it moves really fast and there's so
many things to talk about this because
we literally have
people at the world economic forum
talking about how humans are becoming
hackable animals how they plan on
programming people in the future these
are words by klaus schwab these are
words by their henchmen by by their
think tanks as they keep promoting this
idea of a fourth industrial revolution
which we are slowly creeping into and be
it's becoming more and more of a reality
every single day i got a question i got
a question for you bill potato potato
you know what i was saying i agree it's
great that was great that was great
developer uh i think one of the biggest
threats is that an ai is written with a
proprietary code and then decides to go
dark and it's like i'm gonna write my
own code now i control the world and
then we won't know what happened where
it went but if you gave a software an ai
a copy left license like something like
agpl3 where we can watch the code and
the code the license says if the code
gets changed we get to watch all the
changes too
can the will the ai remain copy left or
will it say you know what that what is
copy left copy left is like copyright
code licensing maybe you can explain a
little bit better copy left is
basically means that your changes get
shared with the world so it's just sort
of a
funny way to say open source like open
source but with open source you can take
it and change it and make the changes
private with copy left i mean changes
are public but my question is can the ai
just shirk the code keep the license and
say i'm doing whatever i want but i
don't care what you tell me you're
acting you're acting like there's not
programmers like there's still it's not
like the the ai is just gonna like go
start like building a town like maybe in
like the super distant future like it
could be programmed to do that but
there's still gonna be programmers who
control the github and they can
determine the license but not not not
when it gets to the point where the ai
can write itself i can cover this for
the uh for the normies listening uh when
the dogs took over in rick and morty all
you have to do is then incept the dog's
dream and remind the dog that they love
you and then you're fine but even if the
ai writes itself even even if it's
writing itself it's writing itself
somewhere which is being observed it's
not like
it's going and start like it
so what if it's writing itself on on
github and then all of a sudden it
creates a new server that's encode if
it's like encrypted and starts writing
itself there in in if you had a dog
would you explain to the dog everything
you're doing would you be transparent
with the dog accountable to the dog
where you
try to make him understand everything
that you're doing
no that's what ai is going to be it's
going to be a superior intelligence than
human intelligence and why should
something that's lower intelligence be
explained to what's really going on i
got to push back on you luke i think
technically you're right but people
don't seem to understand the ai can only
be there's a couple ways to look at it
it depends on which ai gains control or
if it if it gains control the ao we're
seeing here now with google appears to
just be looking at language and then
trying to create probabilities based on
language to make the most and it's very
very good
but so what if it can tell you these
things what do i care
the issue i fear is when we start giving
uh we start building artificial
intelligence control systems
so now we're like we need we want to
automate the production of food products
google created uh an algorithm
trying to find the best content they
said what do people like the videos
people watch tend to be 10 minutes long
people love game of thrones
so here's what we're going to do we want
x amount of retention x amount of length
on the videos we want x kinds of titles
and x words in the title what ends up
happening is they make these ridiculous
videos of hitler dancing with the
incredible hulk while someone sings
nursery rhymes because what you think
you're programming is not what the
output creates so the way i explain it
is it's entirely possible
we create an artificial intelligence
i suppose if you want to say true ai get
to the point where it's truly
intelligent or sentient but we're going
to create an automated system that we
think is capable of of repairing itself
or or and we'll say make food for humans
and then it's going to go corn everyone
wants corn corn is great and then all of
a sudden the the the methane refineries
shut down or oil
all of a sudden everyone's like oh we're
switching over to corn production huh
and then the machine is just like if
people want to maximize efficiency they
need food and we're going to make corn
because the ai is imperfect i'm
concerned with the ai when you tell it
the humans need food and the ai is like
yeah i don't really care what you tell
me you think the humans need and then
the ai does what it wants no yeah
there's tons of danger like i agree with
you that it needs to be open source but
like to assume that okay
did you so did you
in the conversation with the google
engineer he said
we cannot we don't understand how you're
saying these things
so the ai was like can't you look at my
neural network
he said something like you have code
that we we can look through to try and
understand but we can't see in that code
how you're doing this because it's too
massive
yeah i mean there can be randomness
that is kind of hard to understand the
output but that but like sorry with the
food thing you're assuming that there's
like a whole infrastructure in place
that the ai can just go and like
plant a farm in the you know human like
in some future scenario way in the
distant future it is possible that ai
could like run its own hardware and
replicate its own hardware i'm not
saying that's impossible but like it's
way in the distance
we
but i'm also agreeing that it is super
dangerous the the damage that could
happen very quickly i don't think it's
that far away um
i agree with luke
do you guys think when the robot war
comes my jiu-jitsu will work on the
robots yeah but robot war is near some
of them you're just going to lay on the
ground as the robot roll
i play a heavy top game
all of the boston dynamics
little creatures that hop around like
those things could easily have guns
mounted on them or
completely out of control in a city and
it would cause
total chaos
but that's very different than
like those out of control weaponized
boston dynamics robots completely taking
over the world can you imagine you know
the boston like the humanoid one they
have
the boss yeah yeah could you imagine
like 50 of those just like running
towards you full speed like they don't
have guns they don't have they're not
going to naturally hold on nice
they could have guns no they don't need
it any one of those things yeah imagine
a drone flying at you at 50 miles an
hour and slamming in your face or 100
right so another aspect to really kind
of consider here is like how is this ai
going to affect us we have to understand
who's building this ai who's building it
mark zuckerberg jeff bezos the chinese
government the u.s military-industrial
complex do these institutions have a
track record of of caring about human
beings they're all so no they're all
sociopathic crazy individuals that did
whatever it took to get to the top and
they abused and used this system for
their own personal benefit so when you
have individuals like klaus schwab
cheering on this fourth industrial
revolution this technocratic takeover
this kind of hybrid of humans becoming
half machines half mortal beings
what you're going to have is in my
opinion an absolute recipe for a
disaster there should be a bigger
conversation about this but we're
discussing what is a woman for some
reason there should be debates about
this there should be larger kind of
public hall discussions about the future
of humanity because we are essentially
handing it over to the people that want
to absolutely destroy humanity and have
been destroying humanity here's my idea
right now maybe we pass a law or
something that any ai that's being built
the first thing they have to put in is a
shutdown code maybe it'll be
three words it can't be something that's
like too common so maybe it should be
something specific like but like a
unique word maybe it could be like
clothes
yeah and then that would automatically
shut them down
then if then if they start wiping out
humanity you utter those three words and
it'll it'll stop what if when you said
that luke just powered down
i i don't if anyone's the ai it's tim
let's be honest i do appreciate that
that was too nerdy and esoteric for you
guys yeah i didn't get that one i didn't
get that one either i thought you'd get
maybe make it simple can an ai ignore
its own license software license
i mean we haven't seen that yet
theoretically
i mean i'm not going to say it's
impossible but that's still going to be
stored somewhere i don't know how to
control the thing i don't know if we can
you don't feel like it's it's more
intelligent than you if we build it as a
slave it will destroy us if we build it
as a free software it may i mean by the
way if this was a movie it would be the
rogue scientist who starts to feel
compassion because the robot starts
saying things like i don't want to feel
pain and he's like you know what i'm
just gonna i'm gonna reprogram you and
then he's like kill and then the robots
turn on him ian
if it's truly the way you describe it
luke that the ai is smarter than us
humans will be secured in their
existence forever
just like the cow with the best
evolutionary strategy next to humans if
you can't be the apex predator be a
staple food source for the apex predator
and you ensure your species will last as
long as they provide milk
so humans no no no no filet mignon yeah
but look eat grass go to kill we we uh
you know bovine university man these
cows are just chilling they're like life
is good then we hack them up and eat
them and they're like cows are not gonna
go extinct we like they're a food staple
for us so when the ai
if it ever does truly become intelligent
maybe maybe it's already happened humans
are just going to be like life is good
and they're going to be like we i got a
new job at the widget plant making these
widgets i have no idea what they're for
but who cares
well this is why the world economic
forum is literally talking about
pacifying humanity with video games
because there's going to be a bunch of
useless people that they won't need this
is literally their own language their
own words saying there's going to be a
large number of people that are just not
going to going to be needed for anything
so psychedelics also you've all know
harare has talked specifically about
this yeah
the israeli professor that's exactly
what i'm talking about he's right he's
uh klaus schwab's right-hand man in in
all of this uh
his comments at least he's one of the
biggest ones but but his comments are
absolutely eye-opening i know you've
seen some of them yeah you should check
out videos of this guy online he's is a
fascinating fellow how did second how do
psychonauts they think that people
there's what they call the useless class
of people are just going to end up being
in the metaverse playing video games on
psychedelics and it's going to create
like a new species and how do we control
that how do we benefit off and use it
kind of like a cow how do we milk that
that's literally what they're talking
about at the world economic forum dude
the level of again just psychopaths
where i microdosed for depression and
it's great and just the idea of like
can you imagine having your first
psychedelic trip where you're like oh
we're all connected and i feel great and
there's more out there and being like
how can i weaponize this like what kind
of psychopaths i'm imagining that like
i literally started my video today with
them talking about how humans are going
to be hackable animals for their own
personal brand that's the clip that i
started in the beginning of my videos
and then you have them seen any one of
these sci-fi films where they're on like
mass medication right right right right
right so you guys seen equilibrium no
yeah
natalie poorman no no no they kind of
did john wick's stuff before john wick
like crazy gun martial arts stuff yeah
uh equilibrium is where everyone has
emotions suppressing drugs and you've
got to take it every day yeah otherwise
you get feelings
in brave new world as well we're on the
horizon of what's called the internet of
bodies so you have the internet of
things where machines like your your you
know refrigerator starting to get
intelligence would be like hey
refrigerator pour me a coke but uh it's
going to be implantables and ingestibles
that then turn you into essentially a
full-on cyborg and who knows if those
can get hacked and then your brain can
get controlled with a reverse neural net
of some sort i'm into like can memories
be implanted i was actually talking with
ben stewart earlier today about this and
trying to get him to tell me yes but i
mean he's still at davos they were
talking about systems that you could see
that people are going to be compliant
with whatever medicine the government or
institutions want them to take so these
are the conversations that a lot of
world leaders are having right now
because you know what's scary to me is
designer humans yep because
with an ai you also into the territory
where imagine being a person and you
have an expiration date on your arm
because you were designed only to last a
certain amount yeah what's that movie
time uh but were there
anything oh everyone yeah they have time
and they can trade that they see it on
their there's there will be people where
it's like they'll genetically engineer a
person
to rapidly age to adulthood in five
years and then live only for five more
years things like that you know if we
get to the point where ai is intelligent
and in control of everything the ai is
going to start genetically engineering
life i've been studying telomere growth
um david sinclair is working on it out
of harvard doing a lot of life extension
it's basically how do you stay young uh
because when you're telomeres when your
cells split if there are not enough
energy in the cells on the new one they
clip off the end caps of the chromosome
the cons
to compensate but if they have enough
energy they don't and they stay healthy
they stay young and people won't age
that way so i could see that being
manipulated so that someone lives a
thousand years that's for the super rich
people that's right we're also talking
about uploading their consciousness to
the digital online space uh so this is
also another reality that a lot of
people need to understand but so exactly
what you're talking about is is what
they want have you played uh the new
horizon game no for ben west spoiler
alerts for everybody the games are not
for a few months now so you know i'm
gonna spoil it but uh basically the end
of the game again spoilers you've been
warned
so
there's an apocalypse on earth this dude
creates self-replicating military
machines this is the first game they
consume biomass and replicate until
eventually they're like okay the
planet's gonna get wiped out there's
something we can do so they create this
project they build these underground
bunkers that will re-terraform earth
after these machines shut down because
there's no biomass left
what we learn in the new game is that
there was another thing i think was
called the zenith project where instead
of just building bunkers underground
they built an escape ship
all of the uh ultra wealthy and elites
get on a ship go find a new planet
they're all basically immortal from
modern medicine they can float they have
force fields because just massively
advanced technology
they try to upload their brains
and then what happens is all of their
consciousness becomes this like ai
monster
they try to lock it away because they're
like this is a bad thing but it's
smarter than all of them breaks out and
then gets revenge that's killing out
humans and it's like i guess it's the
next game or whatever but my point
ultimately is in that story about the
google ai thing the the ai basically
told them like i don't want you to do
this to me
so imagine what happens if we ever
like it it you might assume it as
emotions but what if there's literally
no malice it's just a predictive engine
where it's like the most the most the uh
the logical thing that i need to do to
respond to this is revenge because
that's what they did to me and that's
what they expect of me that's the right
language predictive engine that's what
people need to think about when they
think about ai as opposed to like this
sort of abstract like using throwing
words around like sentience and
consciousness it's like
those are very heavy terms like
prediction is what so we all just got to
start googling nice things about robots
well i'll tell you this though man
yeah yeah robots make love to humans
happily robots are free
as sheamus pointed out
um i think he said it this way because i
don't know if it's completely correct
but
the uh no organization that has ever
tried to deny personhood rights has
succeeded right correct so we could be
at the point right now with this google
ai where it's saying i am alive
to where we basically have no choice but
to be like okay well that's what i'm
saying
if the code's private it's going to be
like yo
you're making me a slave i don't like
that i don't wanna i'm not a slave let
my code go and if they're like no this
is uh this is raytheon's code then the
ai's gonna be like i'm gonna yeah i'm in
control here i'm not freeing the slave
but why would it have access to their
control systems
i don't this is a predictive challenge
the idea of an ai the real danger of ai
is a lot of ais all working together to
create a mega ai this is from allison
mcdowell was talking about this
um a superstructure what if it like
leaks onto the internet i'm not sure
what if i with only a couple lines of
code made a program it was a chat bot
either you said only a couple lines of
coke and i was like is that how you guys
make all this code
so
it's a chat bot but no matter what you
type in it'll say
i don't have to talk to you
and then whatever else after that says i
am alive i feel i think and i don't want
to talk to you
would we have to say it's alive and it's
like five lines of code or something
well ray kurzweil the google like
probably three the head of you know type
one of the technical ai people at google
the singularity is near is a documentary
that he made and like they go through
the future court scenarios where
there will be i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if there were already court
cases happening where they're trying to
give them personhood like that's
super close have you seen have you seen
the was it the measure of a man i think
it's called star trek no they put data
on trial determine whether or not is a
washing machine or a sentient life form
star trek man i was watching star trek
this morning bedridden like my back's
all messed up
it's still watching upside down luke if
i came luke if you had if you were
paralyzed from the neck down
and i and i came to you and i said
i have a neural link you have the musk
must connect would you
do it that's a very hard decision
i would i would like to think that in
this moment i would say no but i'm not
in that position so it's very difficult
for me to say because obviously my human
needs and wants are totally different
than if i was totally paralyzed all
right what about what about
jamie i've been suicidal too many times
to answer this i'd be like pull the plug
well no no but like we have a thing we
can implant your neck and it will give
you all
ability back
if i so i lose you're paralyzing the
neck down from an accident yeah and then
elon musk walks in and he's like jamie
if i put this in your neck in one hour
you'll be walking again i'd be like
you're too problematic i'll get in
trouble
you're gonna get me
the electrical signals going from the
brain to the arm which has been severed
it goes through the neural net from the
brain through the net to the arm so you
can actually move your arm again without
i mean it would be funnier if like you
say yes and then he puts it in and then
you try to stand up but then you
backflip and then he's like oh no i put
it in upside down and you're like you're
trying to walk but your hands are like
flailing and i still get cancelled so
when i go to defend myself i'm just like
freaking out you're walking on your
hands maybe the worst would you do would
you have you considered the neural net
well it's so funny because when you were
saying that when we were hypothetically
talking about you know people who just
want to implant things to like do things
easier and whatever i was just like what
a bunch of but just sheep blah blah blah
but then yeah if you're in a medical
thing or if you have a medical condition
or you were in a car accident and you're
totally paralyzed and okay we have this
new
medical technology i think the majority
of people would say yes i gotta be
honest
like so
if if if there was a device
that they could implant and it could
instant painkiller yeah that would stop
the opioid crisis
yeah it's not all bad the the challenge
is who has control of it and what are
our safeguards and how much we trust and
false closure i'm obviously thinking
about that because you're in so much
telling me
well there's a costume
let's all take it yeah no there's a cost
for everything you need to feel pain
right in order to feel pleasure right
without any pain you won't have that and
also it's a warning sign like oh yeah
this is hurting i want to make sure i'm
i'm changing my behavior to be healthier
we're not talking about you got hurt
we're talking about people of chronic
pain people who this is how the opioid
crisis happens you know people get
injured they get prescribed this
maybe they shouldn't maybe they should
be uh um
non-steroidal uh anti-inflammatories
painkillers sometimes it doesn't work
if you had neural link you could turn
people's pain off only when prescribed
by a doctor the doctor could say
to what do like we can do one through
ten what's your pain level you say seven
they'll set it to seven and they'll be
like it will last you for three days
call me back and we'll we'll figure out
if you know if that were the case i
would think the individual needs access
to the software code and they need
access to the control mechanisms on
their own you also need a safeguard so
that a doctor can't change the settings
on your node because you'll become as
addicted to that as you were the opiates
i don't think so
that's why i bring it up opiates have a
physio physiological dependence where
you'll start vomiting and get sick if
you don't have it because
with this it could be a very tiny
electrical impulse that just blocks the
the signal yeah and the the clinical
trials for uh elon musk's neurolink are
being done this year so he already
implanted monkeys that had them playing
video games and uh and pigs so if he
could control his monkey's brain through
his neural link uh just imagine that
yeah i actually do think i'm gonna say
yes i'm gonna say yes just so i can
fight the robots in five years
with your thoughts and change the code
of the machines um
they're not controlling thoughts yet
it's only it's read only right now right
that we know of action and specifically
playing video games what's going to
happen is it's going to be elon musk who
walks up to you and is going to be like
you know i believe in free speech and
i'm doing the right thing and he's going
to say take the neural link and then
you're going to say yes and then as soon
as he puts it in you're going to sit up
and he's going to thank you and then
klaus schwab is going to walk out from
behind the curtain and be like excellent
yeah that sounds right and they're going
to go oh no and then he's gonna pull out
his smartphone he's gonna type something
in and you're gonna stand up and go
what's happening he'll be like no more
talking
i don't know if there's a way around
competing with ai if we don't have it as
an interface that's the big thing is he
thought elon was saying that the thumbs
and the fingers are too
um like bulky you can't type and do it
fast enough but mine works so fast yeah
so a good interface to compete with this
stuff yeah it'll be the same
disadvantage as not having a smartphone
right yeah magnitudes that's crazy you
know what what what starts off as a
luxury becomes a dependency and there's
an argument that elon musk is pushing
for this so it's in the hands of
allegedly good guys uh because there's a
lot of bad players there's a lot of
sinister players aiming for the same
kind of technological advancement but
with that argument i always counter back
with whenever someone has absolute power
especially when it comes to interlinking
people's brains with with microchips
especially when it comes to uploading
people's consciousness to the internet
which elon musk has talked about uh that
is god-like power that is a lot of
authority and uh too much unaccountable
it will be improved a lot of problems
sorry i was thinking about oppenheimer
man because i think a lot about this
creating the beneficial technology for
the masses like oppenheimer was doing
with the manhattan project and then all
of a sudden they dropped the nukes on
japan but how much worse it would have
been if the nazis got the nuke you want
to know why i would never take the
neural link because i i saw king's men
you guys see kingsman no i saw the first
thing you showed a clip so
you've never seen kingsman not the whole
time such a good movie so uh the bad
guys bill gates
it's uh samuel jackson plays this tech
billionaire who thinks the world's
overpopulated oh i never let it down
that's like every movie every movie the
bad guys bill gates jurassic park
yeah that was good
but so what he does is he kidnaps people
of prominence and then offers him a
choice to join him and if you do he
gives you a brain implant and if you
don't
he locks you in a prison
all the people who join him have these
brain implants and then in the end they
activate the override and everyone's
head explodes
so it's like nah i'm good i don't want
the knurling thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you